let's go ahead and begin the price of a
handbag after a 15% discount is $170
what was the original price of the
handbag okay so we're gonna re state the
question in the form of a sentence the
original price was blank dollars let's
go ahead and read back through the price
of a handbag so we have a handbag after
a 15% discount is $170 so it's all right
there all ready for you you want to
represent a percentage problem where the
you mark 0% on one end 100% on the other
end and we're going to put the discount
somewhere in here and this is going to
be the sale price and we said that the
sale price was $170 and that the percent
discount the discount would be 15% so
now I've marked my 15 percent I'm going
to put my question mark which is going
to correspond with my final solution to
my answer sentence so I want my question
mark again to only be where the final
solution is going to be notice in this
problem you have you have to find as a
student that 85 percent is the value of
the sale price so we have 85 percent is
$170 I'm going to use the unitary method
where we drop to one unit we
so we were divided by 85 and so one
percent would be equal to two dollars
and I haven't yet gotten here I want to
get the full 100 percent I want to get
the quantity for that so I multiply by
100 on both sides so that 100 percent is
equal to $200 so I would put my answer
in the final answer sentence the
original price was $200
you